I think Gordon Ramsay would entertain
some of these choices so long as I
didn't bring up pineapple and pizza
I'm Nikki
Joe favorite snacks
[Music]
all right first snack for starting a
classic I hope everybody recognizes
these
Cool Ranch Doritos which I will say are
by far and away my favorite chip so my
thing with the Doritos is I look for the
chip that has the most seasoning
and it's got that super iconic speckled
green and red seasoning on there
to me I love them because I feel like
they're the perfect well-rounded chip
they have a bit of tanginess almost like
a buttermilk flavor to them am I allowed
to dump it out on the table is that okay
I don't want to make a mess right off
the bat but every time I eat them I am
always on the hunt for the chip that has
the most seasoning because to me in
terms of color flavor texture just how
well balanced a Cool Ranch Dorito is
that's what makes me appreciate and love
it so much
they're perfect
all right jelly beans this one is
sometimes a little bit polarizing and
I've gotten arguments about butter
popcorn flavored jelly beans they're
certainly artificial The Taste but I
would say it's just good enough that I
can look past the the artificial side of
things and with these I like to look for
the ones that have extra yellow on them
because mentally at least it almost
makes them taste a little bit more
buttered there are certainly times where
I'm cooking or doing something with food
and then I think in my head briefly
would this be something that that Gordon
would be upset about or yell at me for
but it usually doesn't stop me anyway
okay
this is probably the more unique snack
that I might have in my pantry at home
for many people especially if you don't
like seafood you'll never touch these
but they are literally these baby crabs
they come in a really fun package right
you have the big crab that's eating all
the small little crabs but these are
real whole baby crabs that are fried and
then coated in this basically honey and
different Savory spices and herbs my
favorite thing is if you can find a
perfect crab in here a lot of them are
broken
you can take the individual parts and
you can make
a whole crab
like this which is quite fun I went to
Japan once in my life and tasted these
there and I really really like them
you can hear how loud and crunchy those
are
I had to do a one-handed catch at some
point okay these chicken chips I love
them my mom actually showed me these
she's a big health nut and these are
just the Classic ones the Himalayan pink
salt but they have they have a chicken
and waffles flavor that's really good
this is literally
a chip that's made out of chicken
breasts I love chicken my favorite food
is rotisserie chicken so this is a
natural one for me
they're crunchy they're crispy the only
two things I don't like about them are
one they do leave kind of a thicker
coating on your fingers sometimes which
I don't like with with snacks I'll never
lick my fingers the only other thing
that I don't like which is really picky
and I'm gonna make a small mess on the
table again is this is the shape of
these chips I'm okay with things not
being uniform but I feel like they have
absolutely no control over what the
shape of these ships turns out like and
for me that's sort of weird
these ones are great though aren't they
they were good
but look at that
it's ridiculous
you're not gonna throw this one
guarana is this Brazilian drink that I
love I was actually introduced to this
one not too long ago by a friend of mine
it tastes sort of like a combination of
berry and apple and my first feeling was
that it almost tastes a little bit like
a sort of a sweet maybe grenadine-ish
Coca-Cola type flavor guarana the fruit
is in like every energy drink I later
found out so I don't do super well with
caffeine and that's why I can't drink
these that much even though I really
like them but
hmm if you haven't tried this I would
totally encourage that you do because
it's really really good and also just
super unique
sweet
I love seaweed snacks I've had them a
lot they're healthy they're the texture
is really nice I happen to really like
seaweed issue I have with most of the
seaweed snacks the the ones that come in
the little squares is that you can't
really fit them super easily into your
mouth they're a mess you end up with
seaweed flakes all over your whole body
your pants your shirt and so these ones
I like because one
the texture is really nice and sort of
lighter but two it comes in a form where
you can actually eat it I really enjoy
these
all right I love these these splits
pretzels but they're extra dark so
they're a little bit charred they're
cooked a little bit longer
believe it or not
they're called splits because
if you look at them they have these
little sort of Tears in them these
they're split open a little bit when you
look at them carefully
I sometimes do wonder how how many
people actually enjoy these because this
pretzel is basically Jack Black on the
top which is going to be that really
really kind of Rich burnt toast like
Flavor for me I love it this is one of
my go-to late night snacks
all right last one these cookie squares
I have these on a plane for the first
time so there are these perfect perfect
little shortbread cookies
and there was something about them that
when I had them the first time I
actually couldn't believe that they were
handing them out on a plane they were so
good
[Music]
let me see if I can
open up another one
it's almost like trying to do a cheese
Bowl
you can see the caramel in the middle
right
and so that top layer of milk chocolate
Blends in with the caramel I mean
honestly the only way I think they could
improve these
as if they put Nutella instead of the
milk chocolate on top that'd be perfect
[Music]
thank you so much for watching and I
hope you go and check out some of my
favorite snacks and one last thing don't
forget to check out my new cookbook
knife shop it launches on June 13th and
I have a snack section in there
can I have the Cerritos again
see you later
[Music]